hey guys Pete here are you ready for
some more Game of Thrones Season eight
spoilers I know I am and this latest
thing that came out is pretty intense I
do have to warn you though it's like not
a small spoiler it's something that is
pretty big I think compared to some of
the other stuff we've seen so far so if
you're trying not to know what happens
towards the end of Game of Thrones and
you will not want to watch this video so
this is pretty much everything that
happened this week but the first thing
is the thing I just mentioned and it
goes along with some of the Winterfell
spoilers that I talked about in my last
video we know that they've been shooting
there and with news that the cast had
kind of moved on to Iceland which we'll
get into later wasn't sure we'd see much
more from the money glass studios in
northern island but something big just
got posted yesterday and this is what we
saw so the Facebook user Stephen McAuley
posted this video on Facebook and as you
can see this is absolutely the
Winterfell set on fire it's not like a
little bit of flames here and there but
it's the entire filming set just blazing
so there's no real way to look at this
photo and see what's happening in the
video without coming to the conclusion
that the Winterfell is going to fall
like it's going to be destroyed
the Starks ancestral home in the north
will burn down and at least at the point
of this attack it's obvious that there
will be uninhabitable going forward so
they're going to be chased out one thing
that Watchers on the wall noted that I
will bring up here because it's
important even though these are regular
flames this could be from the night king
attacking with Viserion because they've
done this in the past with wildfire and
you know that basically they can't catch
it on fire and blue flame but they can
catch it on fire with regular flame and
then alter the color in post-production
don't jump to the idea that maybe
Daenerys destroys Winterfell that could
be the case obviously but that doesn't
just because it's regular flames doesn't
mean that's what's gonna happen so this
is big I mean they're gonna destroy
Winterfell and Winterfell has been there
for a long time like I said in my other
video we talked about scenes in the
crypts there's a lot of stuff going on
down there
that sort of expedites anything being
found out in there happening really
early on because it doesn't look like
it'll be accessible beyond that so
you're gonna have to tell me what you
think in the comments about this one is
that the night King does Daenerys get
crazy and decide to attack Winterfell
herself
is there another plausible explanation
in the previous video I showed that we
looked like that the Lannister forces
were attacking in the night shooting
that we saw last week so could this be
related to that I don't know him
personally I don't think so if they have
forces and they're trying to enter the
castle then that doesn't really go along
with burning it to the ground plus it's
not an easy thing to do I mean this
pretty much requires dragon fire but I
guess it could be wildfire it could be
Cersei that would be a surprise to me
but it's definitely possible beyond that
this week there was a bunch of different
stuff nothing really as big as what I
just mentioned but we did find out a
little bit more about the filming
schedule on a couple fronts production
designer or art director Deborah Riley
who won an award at the Art Directors
Guild Awards gave up an interview where
she said the ending will be sweet not
just bittersweet but even though she
didn't give him any plot spoilers she
did give us a good little tidbit and
that's that the director miguel zapata
nick is going to be doing a lot of his
big shooting in march according to riley
so if you know Miguel Zapata Nick he did
some of the biggest battle episodes
including hardhome the winds of winter
and the Battle of the bastards and we
expect that since he's doing two
episodes in the final season they're
both probably going to have a big battle
in them so that's something to look
forward to we may get some sightings and
some
from things going on as soon as next
month which will be epic so I mentioned
that the cast was moving to Iceland for
the shooting there which was talked
about in the last video Emilia Clarke
and Kit Harington were both spotted
there and then we got the actors who
play
tormund Gendry Jorah Mormont Samwell
Tarly and Briana Tarth now that is kind
of confusing but all of those actors
except for Harrington and Clarke were
shot eating together like they were all
at the same place at the same time
though the odd man out there is
obviously Samwell because he is now like
Gran's right arm or whatever and you
know to mean there's really no reason
for him to be up north any further than
Winterfell so it kind of makes you think
that this Iceland stuff is not anything
that's in the far north necessarily but
is most likely in the north outside of
Winterfell no I mean you could just
speculate wildly and say oh well Brandon
Sam go to the land of always winter or
something like that but what are the
other guys doing there if that's the
case so they're there shooting and we
don't know what if anything's gonna leak
out of there that's not really that's
pretty harsh conditions up there we got
some good photos out of Iceland last
year but nothing like we got out of
Spain so we'll have to wait and see if
anything comes out of that but a lot of
the big characters were up there they're
spotted there and then we also know that
ties into this is that the filming crews
have shown up in Croatia as well where
they shot all the King's Landing stuff
up until season six it was knowing that
they were gonna go back there and
they're gonna shoot some stuff probably
outdoor stuff at King's Landing it's
gonna be a short shoot according to
Watchers on the wall and they're in
information but there's photos of them
setting up there's photos of the you
know the locations but what's
interesting here is that there's rumors
going around that main cast members are
going to be there and that's includes
Kit Harington who
is in Iceland at the moment I guess they
scheduled it to be back-to-back shoot
was ever gonna happen in Iceland and
then go straight down and shoot in
Croatia so that is pretty exciting to
think about we don't know anything else
yet since they're all up in Iceland
we'll have to wait and see who actually
makes the trip to Croatia to kind of get
a better idea a couple of the main stars
did some interviews this week and Maisie
Williams clarified that in a tweet she
said that that quote that was taken from
her that everybody has accepted and
thought that meant that that's gonna
come out in April she says just a tweet
letting you know this game of Thrones
release date quote I supposedly given is
completely false and taken from an
interview I did years ago so yeah that
isn't there's nothing to that I
mentioned that in my last video that
there probably wasn't and that turns out
to be the case and Peter Dinklage talked
about the really heightened security and
the levels of secrecy that the whole
cast is under right now and how that's
been you know such a long journey of
year after year he kind of talks like he
thinks it's a fun part of it because
they know the story and they don't tell
anyone when he was asked about the
ending of season eight he said and I
quote it was heartbreaking and the end
of an era
so does he mean that the story itself is
heartbreaking
I'm sure that it's somewhat or is he
just talking about the fact that his
participation in the series is coming to
an end so conspicuous
this has been a part of our life for
quite a while now so it's like almost
hard to believe that it's actually going
to come to an end but it definitely is
and I'll be looking at everything I can
find as far as shooting and interviews
and keep these videos coming throughout
the filming process which we expect will
last through summer so that'll give us
plenty to think about in the run-up and
like I said hopefully the whole thing
won't leak again and we'll be able to
speculate rather than having it just
straight up spoiled for us so please
like the video if you enjoyed it go back
and watch my other one if you haven't
seen it there's some
interesting stuff in there make sure you
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already make sure you turn on
notifications after you do that so that
you'll know when my new videos come out
if you're interested in help support the
channel please check out my patreon
account you can always use help over
there because Adsense just isn't what it
used to be anymore that's all for now
guys thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon